Jake: 看表了
Jake: Check the time.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:坐后边玩手机
Alice: Sitting in the back playing on my phone.
Alice:感觉晕车了
Alice: Feeling a bit car sick.
Jake: 到了是吧
Jake: We've arrived, right?
Jake: 确实到了
Jake: Yeah, we are here.
Jake:进去
Jake: Let's go in.
Shure: ok成
Shure: Okay, got it.
Jake:进去进去找
Jake: Go in, go in and look.
其他人：够荒凉的
Others: It's quite desolate.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 咱也不知道这是啥地
Jake: We don't even know what place this is.
其他人：嗯信号不好
Others: Yeah, bad signal.
Jake: 皇家新村
Jake: Royal New Village.
其他人：信号不好啊
Others: The signal is bad, huh?
其他人：走了呢
Others: They left.
其他人：应该就这位置了100米
Others: It should be around here, within 100 meters.
Jake: 那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人：是不就这
Others: Is it just here?
Shure:  好像不是这个
Shure: Seems like it's not here.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
其他人：不是再往前大铁门
Others: No, go further, there's a big iron gate.
Jake: 我我等会
Jake: Wait a second.
Jake: 我我我这边看看
Jake: Let me check this side.
其他人：它不动了
Others: It's not moving.
Jake: 我这边也有地图可以看
Jake: I have a map on this side too.
Alice:是65号
Alice: It's number 65.
Jake: 往前走往前走一会
Jake: Walk forward for a bit.
其他人：往前走
Others: Walk forward.
其他人：信号不好
Others: The signal is bad.
Jake: 就这个就左边这个
Jake: It's this one, the one on the left.
Shure:  对这个口停就行
Shure: Yeah, stop at this entrance.
Shure:  您开一下我这侧门吧
Shure: Can you open my door here?
Shure:  这边手动的啊
Shure: This side is manual.
其他人： 这边手动的啊
Shure:  谢谢您
Shure: Thank you.
Shure:  稍等我把手机放兜里
Shure: Hold on, let me put my phone in my pocket.
Shure:  哎呦呦怎么还迷糊了呢
Shure: Oh no, why am I feeling dizzy?
Shure:  哎好成谢谢你
Shure: Alright, thanks a lot.
Katrina: 我猜是往这吧
Katrina: I guess it's this way.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 对了应该这有紫藤花
Katrina: Right, there should be wisteria here.
Shure:  你太聪明
Shure: You are so smart.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Shure:  再往前是吗
Shure: Move forward more?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Is that right?
Katrina: 是的这有一个
Katrina: Yes, there's one here.
Shure:  左拐吗还是右拐
Shure: Turn left or right?
Katrina: 猜一下呗
Katrina: Guess.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Alice:还往前
Alice: Keep going forward.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 再往前不是了吧
Shure: Keep going forward, right?
Tasha:  再往前
Tasha: Keep going.
Alice:还得往前
Alice: Still forward.
Tasha:  往前
Tasha: Forward.
Shure:  ah
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 31右转
Katrina: Turn right at 31.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  可以啊
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  牛
Shure: Awesome.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my.
Shure:  J人不记路
Shure:  靠P人记路呢怎么
Katrina: 勾人这脑子
Katrina: Rely on others' brains.
Shure:  好困
Shure: So sleepy.
Katrina: 勾人不是万能的
Katrina: Relying on others is not all-powerful.
Shure:  我也不想整了
Shure: I don't want to do it anymore.
Shure:  想直接睡觉
Shure: Just want to sleep.
Katrina: 我也想睡觉了
Katrina: I want to sleep too.
Katrina: 我这还有两个会要开
Katrina: I still have two meetings to attend.
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Ugh.
Katrina: 能到时候他们先准备
Katrina: Can they prepare first?
Katrina: 等会我来洗碗吧
Katrina: I'll do the dishes later.
Katrina: 现在可能没啥空
Katrina: Now I might not have much time.
Katrina: 但现在应该要先腌
Katrina: But now we should marinate first.
Katrina: 那个是不是
Katrina: Is that right?
Shure:  对它在添自己的蛋蛋
Shure: Yeah, it's licking its balls.
Shure:  蛋蛋别舔了
Shure: Stop licking your balls.
Katrina: 910325 是不是
Katrina: 910325, right?
Shure:  好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it.
Katrina: 我不记得啊
Katrina: I don't remember.
Shure:  不对
Shure: No, that's not right.
Shure:  摁下那个星号
Shure: Press the star button.
Jake: 你家是刚刚有猫吗
Jake: Did you just get a cat at your place?
Shure:  7多少多少来着
Shure: What's the 7 something something?
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Meow meow.
Shure:  不是如果你摁对了
Shure: No, if you pressed it right.
Shure:  他直接自己开
Shure: It would open automatically.
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Meow meow.
Jake: 你你要先按一个键
Jake: You need to press one button first.
Jake: 然后再310
Jake: Then 310.
Jake: 再再对你等到他
Jake: Then wait until it beeps.
Jake: 哔对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yes!
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: Awesome, awesome.
Shure:  哦太牛了
Shure: Oh, so cool!
Shure:  人类居然可以记住6位密码
Shure: Humans can actually remember a 6-digit code.
Shure:  小心点那有那有
Shure: Watch out, there's something there.
Shure:  钉子好像
Shure: Looks like a nail.
Jake: 经过了3天的训练
Jake: After 3 days of training.
Shure:  哈哈笑死
Shure: Haha, that's hilarious.
Shure:  人类记住这串密码需要3天的训练
Shure: It took humans 3 days of training to remember that code.
Shure:  AI 3秒用吗
Shure: AI can do it in 3 seconds.
Shure:  用的
Shure: Really.
Jake: 三秒开玩笑
Jake: 3 seconds? You're joking.
Shure:  3毫秒
Shure: 3 milliseconds.
Alice:三秒
Alice: Three seconds.
Lucia:  这么简单的事情就不用3秒了是吧
Lucia: Something this simple doesn't even take 3 seconds, right?
Shure:  小艾特他没有开灯
Shure: Little AI didn't turn on the lights.
Jake: 3秒带开机吗
Jake: 3 seconds with booting up?
Shure:  开着呢
Shure: It's on.
Jake: 三秒开机
Jake: 3 seconds to boot.
Shure:  开灯吧
Shure: Turn on the lights.
Jake: 放冰箱放完冰箱就结束
Jake: Put it in the fridge and we're done.
Lucia:  我的留言板
Lucia: My message board
Lucia:  不是留言板
Lucia: Not a message board
Lucia:  就是那个软木的那个照片墙
Lucia: It's that cork photo wall
Katrina: 这个肉要腌吗
Katrina: Does this meat need to be marinated?
Katrina: 还是说先放冰箱
Katrina: Or should we put it in the fridge first?
Lucia:  这个东西
Lucia: This thing
Lucia:  它怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why is it so big?
Lucia:  我以为它就一点点呢
Lucia: I thought it was just a little bit
Lucia:  装起来就好
Lucia: Just pack it up
Katrina: 把肯德基扔了
Katrina: Throw away the KFC
Shure:  我每天放冰箱的意义
Shure: The point of putting it in the fridge every day
Shure:  就是留一天扔掉是吗
Shure: Is to leave it for a day and then throw it away, right?
Shure:  好饿好饿
Shure: So hungry, so hungry
Shure:  好困好困好累好累
Shure: So sleepy, so sleepy, so tired, so tired
Lucia:  算了一会再看他
Lucia: Forget it, I'll check on him later
Shure:  （歌词）嘟呀嘟
Shure: (Lyrics) Doo ya doo
Jake: 好空
Jake: So empty
Shure:  需要都放里吗
Shure: Do we need to put everything in?
Katrina: 鸡蛋呢
Katrina: What about the eggs?
Katrina: 扔了
Katrina: Throw them away
Shure:  鸡蛋放放放
Shure: Put the eggs, put, put
Shure:  然后导完
Shure: Then after pouring
Lucia:  然后把新的再补充进去
Lucia: Then refill with the new ones
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello
Shure:  导完就给我然后我就开始
Shure: After pouring, give it to me, then I'll start
Lucia:  再不吃可能坏了
Lucia: If we don't eat it soon, it might go bad
Jake: yes yes
Jake: Yes, yes
Shure:  为什么他要听RMB
Shure: Why does he have to listen to RMB
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  这个小狗
Shure: This puppy
Jake: RMB
Lucia:  哦对芒果
Lucia: Oh right, the mango
Shure:  不用不用
Shure: No need, no need
Shure:  电子版扫描就行
Shure: Just scan the electronic version
Tasha: 这 门被开过了
Tasha: This door has been opened
Tasha:  你刚开的是吧
Tasha: You just opened it, right?
Lucia:  我们晚上可以把
Lucia: We can...
Katrina: 这4个吃了吧占位置
Katrina: Let's eat these 4, they're taking up space
Lucia:  让我们那啥
Lucia: Let us...
Lucia:  做那些甜品的时候需不需要用
Lucia: When making those desserts, do we need to use...
Jake: 吃
Jake: Eat
Jake: 今晚做什么呀
Jake: What are we making tonight?
Katrina: 对这个吗
Katrina: This one?
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah
Tasha:  都可以
Tasha: Anything's fine
Jake: 你你烤他甜点
Jake: You, you bake him a dessert
Lucia:  就草莓和芒果
Lucia: Just strawberries and mangoes
Lucia:  好像微微之前说做甜点用
Lucia: I think Tasha mentioned using them for dessert
Jake:烹
Jake: Cook
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia:  可以先放一下
Lucia: We can set them aside for now
Lucia:  然后如果用不着了再把它吃掉
Lucia: And if we don't need them, we can eat them later
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one
Jake: 热量爆炸是吧
Jake: It's gonna be high-calorie, right?
Lucia:  芒果
Lucia: Mango
Lucia:  怎么给我一种好像要尽快吃它的感觉
Lucia: Why do I get the feeling we need to eat it soon
Jake: 今天就吃
Jake: Let's eat it today
Jake:吃
Jake: Eat
Lucia:  再放可能就
Lucia: If we leave it, it might...
Tasha:  那就今天就吃
Tasha: Then let's eat it today
Jake: 今天今天围绕着他能做什么
Jake: What can we make with it today
Katrina: 我的ice cream
Katrina: My ice cream
Tasha:  什么都行
Tasha: Anything's fine
Lucia:  对会今天把它做了
Lucia: Yeah, let's make it today
Jake: 对今天围绕着他
Jake: Yes, let's focus on it today
Shure:  我我们我可以
Shure: I, we, I can
Shure:  我们可以养小芒狗
Shure: We can raise a little mango dog
Lucia:  养小芒狗
Lucia: Raise a little mango dog
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 哈哈哈芒果核这个我知道
Jake: Hahaha, mango seed, I know that
Shure:  你知道那个吗
Shure: You know that one?
Alice:就那个芒果盒
Alice: Yeah, that mango seed
Tasha:  芒果皮芒果狗是吧嗯
Tasha: Mango skin, mango dog, right?
Shure:  芒果核对
Shure: Mango seed, yes
Lucia:  哦没反应过来
Lucia: Oh, I didn't get it
Alice:让他把它嗦嗦嗦
Alice: Let him suck on it
Lucia:  哎我鞋带没有开
Lucia: Oh, my shoelace didn't come untied
Shure:  对嗦嗦干净点
Shure: Yes, suck it clean
Lucia:  行今天晚上的活动就是养小小芒果
Lucia: Okay, tonight's activity is raising a little mango dog
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright
Lucia:  芒果核
Lucia: Mango seed
Shure:  不行今天太多了
Shure: No, we have too much today.
Shure:  明天明天养吧
Shure: Let’s do it tomorrow.
Shure:  工作量爆棚了有点
Shure: The workload is a bit overwhelming.
Jake: 养芒果要工序很多吗
Jake: Does growing mangoes involve a lot of steps?
Shure:  啊不需要需要
Shure: Ah, no, it does, it does.
Lucia:  用就一直搁那吸那个芒果核就行了
Lucia: Just keep it there and let it absorb the mango seed.
Jake: 一直吃是吧
Jake: Keep eating it, right?
Shure:  嗦干净一点就好
Shure: Just clean it up a bit.
Lucia:  然后洗一洗
Lucia: Then wash it.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake: 迷惑行为是吧不知道
Jake: Confusing behavior, right? Don’t know.
Shure:  嗦干净对
Shure: Clean it up, yes.
Shure:  人类为什么会把一个植物的种子
Shure: Why would humans treat a plant seed
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  当成一个宠物
Shure: as a pet?
Shure:  why human will
Shure: Why human will...
Shure:  布拉布拉布拉
Shure: Blah, blah, blah...
Jake: 挺好好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 6:11
Shure:  我靠那是7点 能吃啊
Shure: Damn, that’s 7 o'clock. Can eat?
Jake: 7点开始可达到
Jake: Starts at 7 o'clock, can reach.
Jake: 7点开始做
Jake: Start at 7 o'clock.
Alice:开始做快8点吃
Alice: Start at 7, eat around 8.
Shure:  能快速的把我这个先导完吗
Shure: Can you quickly finish this first?
Jake: 哈哈哈呃没没法快
Jake: Hahaha, uh, no, can’t be fast.
Shure:  做不到是吗
Shure: Can't do it, right?
Tasha:  哎牛奶怎么拿出来了
Tasha: Hey, why did you take out the milk?
Alice:是早上的时候吧
Alice: It’s from this morning, right?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure:  卧槽
Shure: Damn.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia:  现在应该还不至于坏
Lucia: It shouldn't be bad yet.
Shure:  那个蛋液好像够呛
Shure: The egg mixture seems questionable.
Jake: 蛋液怎么会呢
Jake: How could the egg mixture be bad?
Shure:  那可以停了吗这个先
Shure: Can we stop this now?
Jake: 结束了吧结束了吧
Jake: It's done, it's done.
Shure:  结束了吧
Shure: It's done.
Shure:  我这个快结束
Shure: I'm almost done with this.
Jake: 来快快结束
Jake: Come on, quickly finish it.
Katrina: 面包要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should we put the bread in the fridge?
Shure:  不然的话大家那吃吃上就得饿死了
Shure: Otherwise, everyone will starve while eating.
Lucia:  面包
Lucia: Bread.
Lucia:  要不咱们拿到楼上去放楼上冰箱
Lucia: How about we take it upstairs and put it in the upstairs fridge?
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia:  菜就不放
Lucia: Let's not put the vegetables.